okay so in this video we're gonna go
over some of the stages and facts of the
nitrogen cycle now one problem that
we're gonna encounter
when you talk about the nitrogen cycle
is that the majority of our atmosphere
about 78% of our atmosphere is filled
with nitrogen that's not the problem the
problem is that the nitrogen is unusable
to life when you look at this picture
right here n2 is the chemical formula
for the atmospheric nitrogen and notice
how there are triple bonds there's a
triple bond holding this nitrogen
atmospheric nitrogen and two together
triple bonds aren't very very stable
hard to break so that's the reason why
nitrogen is just not usable to most
forms of life most forms of life can't
break the triple bonds but there are
some forms that can and you'll get into
that in just a moment so nitrogen is
really important and one reason is
because it helps to build DNA molecules
here is a double helix in the picture
and if we look at this picture right
here remember it reminds us what a
nucleotide is DNA is made from a Hulk a
whole large collection of nucleotides
and one of the parts of a nucleotide is
called a nitrogenous base a nitrogen
base therefore implying it's made from
nitrogen so nitrogen is at the very
heart of DNA molecules one of the
reasons why we need to understand how
the nitrogen cycle works
so let's go ahead and look at the cycle
now step one we're gonna break this down
into six different areas in the picture
so area one step one bacteria are gonna
do a process called nitrogen fixation in
the animation the bacteria in the
animation are taking in atmospheric
nitrogen and two and two molecule from
the atmosphere and they're gonna do the
process called nitrogen fixation and
they're gonna convert the atmospheric
nitrogen into ammonium and from the
animation you can see ammonium x'
formula is NH 4 so that right there is
the first step the process called
nitrogen fixation but then next comes
step number 2 which is a process called
nitrification similar in name however
there's a bit of a difference
nitrification still uses soil bacteria
notice an area - of the animation NH 4
which is the ammonium is going to be
converted into no.3 which are nitrates
this is a more usable form so the
purpose of nitrogen fixation and
nitrification is to convert atmospheric
nitrogen which is not usable really into
more usable forms so that's the the job
of area number 2 of the bacteria in area
number 2 called nitrification well
there's still bacteria in area number 3
and these bacteria in area number 3 do a
process called denitrification so like
it says in the notes soil bacteria are
going to use those nitrates the no.3 is
the nitrates and in the word denied to
phi you can see that they're gonna
remove the nitrogen so they're gonna
denitrification it's a waste gas to them
but they're using the oxygen for their
cellular needs so I notice when you look
at the animation we already have a
nitrogen cycle we already have a
complete cycle involving just bacteria
and we haven't even gotten to plants and
animals yet
you
so when we look at the area for of our
diagram we're now going to involve
plants there's a plant in the middle of
the picture that's symbolic of our
producer and in the arrows the arrows
you can see that no.3 the nitrates are
being absorbed through the roots of the
plant well now that there's nitrogen in
the plant
I hope it's pretty straightforward what
happens next
nitrogen simply moves up the food chain
we have a little rodent in area number
five of our picture and nitrogen is
going from the plant into the rodent
that's because the rodent eats the plant
and so nitrogen simply moves up the food
chain a snake my teeth rodent a hawk
might eat the snake and so on up the
food chain and then we have some
decomposers in the middle of the picture
and it says decomposers are gonna obtain
nitrogen by feeding on the dead so in
the animation there's nitrogen going
from the plant and from the rodent
because when plants and rodents die
they're dead remains are fed on by
decomposers such as bacteria and fungus
while every organism creates waste and
decomposes are no different there
decomposers are responsible for a
process called ammonification and in the
word ammonification i hope you can see
the prefix for ammonium what
ammonification is it completes this
cycle is decomposers will give off NH 4
we saw NH 4 earlier NH 4 is ammonium
which is created by the nitrogen fixing
bacteria so notice how we have almost
like an outer cycle in the animation and
almost like an inner cycle in the
animation but notice how there is a
complete nitrogen cycle when you examine
this animation here the main trick of
course is to understand the various if
occations the ammonification is the
nitrogen fixation x' that's going to be
the challenge for you this chapter
so before we're finished I want to
mention the role that lightning has in
the nitrogen cycle lightning can help
break apart some of that end to remember
n2 atmospheric nitrogen is really stable
and so one way that that the end to the
atmospheric nitrogen can be broken apart
is through the energy within lightning
in our animation we have some lightning
bolts flashing and watch what happens
the end twos and the O twos that are in
the atmosphere are broken apart because
the energy from lightning breaks apart
the chemical bonds and so what happens
is ones once those ends and O's are
broken apart they're gonna bond to form
nitrogen oxides like you see right now
well one thing you should know is that
with lightning often accompanies rain
and so the nitrogen oxides watch what
happens when it starts raining the
nitrogen oxides are going to react with
water to form nitrates no.3 and you've
seen nitrates before nitrates were
created by nitrogen fixing bacteria so
once it rains the nitrates are simply
carried down and added into the soil and
those nitrates simply become a part of
the nitrogen cycle so that's a neat
little way that that lightning can add
usable nitrogen into the soil
so wrapping up here is a little practice
quiz go ahead and pause the video and if
you're in my biology class
by all means write your answers on a
separate sheet of paper I need to be
happy to check you check your answers
before or after class one day so go
ahead and pause the video good luck